at least four people have been killed
and 16 injured in drone strikes and
Ukraine's Capital officials say key was
struck several times in an early morning
attacked by Russian forces using drugs
as mayor says they hit the Central
shevichen District the area was shelled
by Russia last week let's bring in
Muhammad Jam in Kiev so Muhammad what's
the feeling on the streets there given
what's happened the last few hours
well Nick interestingly enough it's
relatively calm right now the air alert
system has now sent out an alert in the
last half an hour or so saying that
everything is back to normal it's given
the city the all clear it's so common in
fact in the neighborhood that we're in
right now that I'm actually overlooking
at the moment a children's playground
where there are kids playing on slides
and swings that really gives you a sense
of how quickly things change here in
Kiev it was just early this morning that
our team was awakened by the air raid
sirens that were sounding out throughout
the city we were looking up at the sky
at different points and seeing those
Kamikaze drones trying to hit targets
then we'd hear the rattat sound coming
from the air defense systems they were
trying to shoot those those drones down
now as you mentioned four people
confirmed killed in Kiev that happened
in a residential building that was badly
damaged as a result of those drone
strikes in the center of the city where
the attacks took place and the mayor of
the city Vitale Klitschko he said that
one of the victims was an elderly lady a
resident of that building and the two
other of the victims were a married
couple a man and a woman who was six
months pregnant so certainly a very
tragic news for the residents of that
building we've also heard that there
were three people killed in attacks on
the Sumi oblast region that's on the
border with Russia now at the moment
there are some concerns that this could
affect the power grid in the country
because local officials have said that
there were many critical infrastructure
Targets in different cities and regions
that were targeted by these drone
strikes today but you have officials
that have tried to ease people's
concerns saying that even though some
facilities were damaged the power grid
is up and running yes there were power
outages and hundreds of villages but
they say that everything should be back
online and back to normal within the
coming hours one more thing to mention
we also got a news just about an hour
ago that Ukrainian presidential advisor
Alexi erstovich said that Ukrainian air
different system shot down three
missiles that were heading towards uh
this Capital City Kiev in the last few
hours as well so even though things
relatively calm at this hour when we
were speaking to Residents earlier in
the day closer to the attack site they
were saying that this really goes to
show just how things can change so
quickly and that on a day like today
when those Air Raid Sirens were ringing
out they wanted to try to get to those
shelters as quickly as possible Nick of
course all right Muhammad leave it there
thanks very much Mohammed James
reporting from Keith